[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation acidic cannabinoids
inactive precursors or powerful
therapeutics this webinar is part of the
10th annual neuroscience virtual
conference and i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by labyrinths
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using the new live
chat feature
during your presentation
you can find that live chat located at
the right of your screen you can also
participate by submitting many questions
as you want during the presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow that
process to obtain your credits without
further ado i now present our speaker dr
dustin sulak the founder and medical
director of integrate health and
co-founder of healer.com for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the left of your
screen
dustin welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much a pleasure to have
this opportunity to share this exciting
information with your audience today
thank you for the invitation so i'm
dustin sulak i'm an osteopathic
physician a general practitioner my
practice is focused on integrative
medicine kind of the intelligent
combination of conventional and
complementary alternative medicine and
medical cannabis i've had great
opportunities to
learn about cannabis and to teach it and
kind of participate in this quickly
growing field and i've been doing this
for about 12 years i'll start with a
little story i practice here in maine
where we've had
somewhat of a different medical cannabis
program compared to a lot of states
we have a small population but literally
thousands of different cannabis
producers so the marketplaces always had
a lot of artisanal kind of homemade
small scale
products and and patients are often
trying lots of different things
especially earlier in my career so back
in 2013 after sanjay gupta aired the
first weed documentary and showed
charlotte figgy getting better with cbd
my practice went from mostly adults with
ptsd chronic pain cancer things like
that to this very
kind of heavy emphasis of pediatric
neurology not just seizures but other
neurologic cases were coming in to see
me and at that time uh
2013 or 14 there were no um labeling no
lab testing no real understanding of
what was in the different products my
patients were using and the stakes were
now higher because i'm treating a lot of
pediatrics and i thought well i really
need to find out what's in all these
products so we set up a high performance
liquid chromatography
machine here in the office and we
started testing the products that people
were making or that they were using some
some of them bought
from the dispensaries which had not been
in business very long there and we found
some interesting things and this is what
started to clue me in to the acidic
cannabinoids so one quick story is that
i had a patient
who came in for seizure she was about 13
very severe seizure she was having about
20 of them a day so this is a case where
it's very obvious and easy to tell like
is something working or not working mom
uh bought a product from the dispensary
that was she was told was a cbd product
nobody knew the potency of it she
started giving it to her daughter and it
started working seizures were gone on
some days and very few on some other
days
they came back for a visit i thought oh
this is great we just set up this
equipment let's test i want to know how
many milligrams of cbd this patient is
using uh in in this effective treatment
and so we looked inside the product and
we did not see any cbd at all we also
barely saw any thc what this was uh
was a glycerin
infusion of cannabis that had a very low
level of thca in it
and i you know thought oh this how could
this be right you know first of all it's
such a tiny amount of thca how could
this be affecting her seizures and no
it's all about cbd because that's what
everybody was thinking at the time we
retested it and it was certainly thca
and then a week or two later i had
another patient come in who also found
benefits with seizures from the same
exact product that was a weak thca
infused
glycerite so that that kind of got my
attention around that same time there
was a tincture that a lot of my patients
were using from a caregiver in western
maine
that just seemed way more effective than
what other people had been exposed to
you know i kept getting these rave
reviews about this tincture so of course
i wanted to get my hands on it and take
a look at what was in it and it was
surprising to me to find that it was
half thc and half thca so it was only
half decarboxylated we'll talk about
what that means and again i thought well
something about this thca is is doing
something for people maybe
it's not an inactive precursor which is
what we had basically been told there
was a little bit of data on it up into
that point that it had some therapeutic
properties but not not much was known
certainly not by myself
everyone had considered thc a to be the
inactive precursor of thc and it turns
out that is not the case so i have a
whole bunch of data for you today to
share what do we know about the acidic
cannabinoids primarily thca and cbda and
then at the end of the presentation
we'll uh talk about you know kind of
practical applications how you can work
this into your own lives or that of your
clients or patients and then i'll be
happy to take questions
uh so these are uh some of the topics
that we'll be reviewing today um the
acidic versus natural cannabinoids
preclinical studies on the therapeutic
effects and mechanisms of action
pharmacokinetic studies which means how
is this stuff absorbed and metabolized
in the body
human clinical evidence we'll review a
recent study that made a lot of
headlines about the acidic cannabinoids
versus covid19 and then strategies for
clinical use
so to start off as i mentioned earlier
the acidic cannabinoids are precursors a
lot of people are actually very
surprised to learn that the cannabis
plant does not make thca
excuse me it does not make thc it does
not make cbd it actually makes a
precursor to these compounds thca and
cbda and then those compounds will
convert into their neutral counterparts
now the a stands for acid and if you
look at this diagram here you can see
for example cbga which is kind of the
primordial cannabinoid the first one
that the plant makes it gets turned into
thca
by an enzyme called thca synthase and
then
with heat
that thca is decarboxylated now the term
decarboxylation literally refers to this
carboxylic acid group here this
o h and o that i'm circling with my
mouse pointer and then that will leave
as carbon dioxide with heat and you can
see that that group is gone so that's
that's where the term decarboxylation
comes from and thca is converted into
thc same thing happens here cbga is
converted by the plant to cbda and then
with heat they can
it can
transform into cbd and i just realize
you can't see my mouse pointer but i
think you're probably
following along we're in the middle row
of this diagram
and on the center of the page here
and then you can see this is the same
case for the other cannabinoids now in
the bottom right we have a time
temperature graph of how thca is
converted into thc and you can see that
at lower temperatures like 80 degrees
centigrade that conversion happens very
slowly and at higher temperatures like
145
centigrade
of course that conversion happens much
more rapidly and so left at room
temperature slowly you'll get some thca
converting the thc but a lot of people
when they're making cannabis products
are under the impression that they
really want to convert all of that thca
to thc or all of that cbda into cbd and
they're actually missing out on a lot of
therapeutic properties when they apply
high levels of heat and or pressure to
these cannabis products
so let's talk about what we know first
of all thca is pharmac pharmacologically
distinct from thc
most important point about this is that
thca does not seem to act upon the cb1
receptor or the cb2 receptor which are
the main targets of thc in the body so
we expect these compounds to behave very
differently there's no psychoactivity
associated with thca this has been
tested in fairly high doses in monkeys
mice and dogs but we do know that thca
modulates the immune system it has
anti-inflammatory properties
neuroprotective meaning it protects the
brain and neurons and also anti-cancer
or anti-neoplastic properties some
examples are listed on this slide thca
has been shown to suppress the release
of tumor necrosis factor alpha
not via a cb1 or cb2 mechanism of action
thca has also been shown to scavenge
free radicals and to inhibit the growth
of cancer in breast and prostate cell
lines
there's been models of inflammatory
bowel disease in vitro and ex vivo
meaning in vitro would be you know kind
of like a test tube type of petri dish
study ex vivo meaning taking animal
tissue out of the animal and then
studying it that way
both both of those models have
demonstrated anti-inflammatory effects
of thca
without the biphasic pro-inflammatory
effects seen with cbd now let's talk
about that for just a second biphasic
dose response effects means and we see
this all over cannabis that in a number
of settings if you kind of start at a
very low dose and you start increasing
the dose you'll see better and better
results like in this model less the
inflammation goes down we increase the
dose the inflammation goes down again
now sometimes in this case with cbd if
you increase the dose enough you
actually get the opposite thing
happening see the inflammation starts
getting stronger and stronger and so
that's that was the case with cbd in
these inflammatory bowel disease models
it was not the case with thca it did not
seem to have that biphasic
pro-inflammatory effect
now there was also one study
that came out that was very interesting
suggesting that thca might be a positive
allosteric modulator at the cb1 receptor
so so what does that mean this is
something that researchers have been
looking for a positive allosteric
modulator of cb1 would make a really
good drug basically we make
endocannabinoids all throughout our
lives and those endocannabinoids target
the cb1 and cb2 receptor for the purpose
of keeping us healthy responding to
illness responding to injury and
bringing the system back into balance
now when we use thc we are directly
targeting the cb1 receptor with the thc
and maybe kind of overriding our
endocannabinoid system especially if
we're using high doses of it but
researchers have been interested in what
if there's something we could take that
wouldn't directly stimulate cb1 but it
would make our endocannabinoid activity
at cb1
more effective or a little stronger
that's called a positive allosteric
modulator and it appears that thca does
this so this might be one of the really
interesting mechanisms of action of how
even though it's not directly affecting
the cannabinoid receptors it could be
making both our endocannabinoids and
other compounds like thc
work a little bit better and this
is congruent with my clinical
observations
now there are some similarities between
thc and thca
and those similarities are outside of
the cb1 and cb2 receptors so all of
these receptor targets that you see in
the first bullet point trip m8 trip a1
these are cation channels and there's a
lot of overlap in the pharmacology
between thc and thca
at these channels particularly the ones
listed on the page here and some of
these are are probably therapeutic
targets
the ethno botanical and anecdotal
reports of the healing properties of
cannabis tea which are you know come out
of jamaica morocco other places that
have traditional cannabis use
well cannabis tea contains very little
thc its primary
its primary compound that it's
delivering is likely thca in most of
these settings so we have this kind of
historical and ethnobotanical
evidence that thca is valued in those
cultures and and effective
then also something to consider is that
it's almost impossible to get pure thca
even at very cold temperatures
there's always going to be at least a
tiny amount of thc present now in some
cases the dose of thca that's effective
can be very low and so we might think
well yes thc could be a confounder this
person or the subject or this animal is
getting a little thc but it's such a
tiny dose it probably doesn't make any
difference
but i always like to keep an open mind
about that because there have been some
studies where ridiculously low doses of
thc
have had profound physical effects now
this is an ultra low dose of thc
this would be low for a human this is
extraordinarily low for a rodent
.002 milligrams per kilogram yet in
three different studies this dose of thc
has been shown to protect against a
heart attack and mice protect against
liver injury and mice and also activate
long-acting
signaling molecules that protect the
brain also in mice so
there's always a potential confounder
with thca
and it's kind of impossible to use thca
without getting little bits of thc so
this is just something that we have to
accept anytime we talk about treating
someone with thca we have to know
there's a little thc in the background
and that possibly it's actually doing a
lot more than we think it is because
tiny doses can do something
now let's move on to cbd
unlike this kind of thca and thc
dichotomy where they're actually quite
different cbda and cbd have a lot more
overlap their pharmacological properties
are similar in a lot of ways there are
some differences which we'll cover but
cbda has superior bioavailability it
gets absorbed much better into the body
and it's also been shown to be more
potent so not only more bioavailable but
more effective at lower doses
similar to thca it has not been found to
act upon the cb1 or the cb2 receptor
but it does share cbd's ability to
activate the 5-ht-1a serotonin receptor
and it does so much more strongly now
this receptor has
been
shown to be a major part or the the main
target of cbd when it's working to
suppress nausea and to relieve anxiety
and we suspect that a lot of the
benefits that most cbd users experience
are actually
more likely due to the serotonergic
effect so cbda mimics that but it does
so even more strongly
cbda has been shown to be an antagonist
a gpr 55 this is thought to be one of
the anti-epileptic mechanisms of action
of cbd so they likely share those
properties and then as you can see uh
some overlapping uh targets with some of
these cation channels cbda has also been
shown to inhibit tumor necrosis factor
alpha and i i think i failed to explain
this earlier tnf alpha is a major
inflammatory signaling molecule in the
body that's implicated in a lot of
autoimmune and rheumatologic diseases
cbda has also been shown to inhibit the
cox-2 enzyme in particular so this would
be
the target of the nsaid drugs these
cox-1 and cox-2 enzymes and of course
there are some cox-2 specific drugs out
there as well this is an enzyme that
metabolizes
fatty acid precursors into inflammatory
compounds
and um and compounds that have the
salicylic acid moiety in their structure
like aspirin like the cannabinoids
can be cox inhibitors now if you
in vitro study that was published in
2008 you can see that thc thca
cbd and cbda were all compared to two
well-known pharmaceutical agents that
also
have been shown to inhibit these enzymes
endomethacin and diclofenac and what you
can see i think the one that really
stands out is at the very bottom of the
chart
cbda was a strong inhibitor of the cox-2
enzyme with a potency about the same as
diclofenac so this is another mechanism
of action of anti-inflammatory effects
and for people that are trying to use
something like cbda that might be more
gentle on the stomach it seems to be
than say taking an advil or an aspirin
this might support that use case
so now we're going to do do a tour of
thca and cbda and animal models and
we're going to start with acute nausea
and i think you'll find
some of this data really interesting and
compelling
so
first of all thca this is a study from
2013 was shown to have anti-emetic or
anti-nausea and vomiting effects that
are superior to thc without the
psychoactive effects now in this animal
model of nausea the dose of thc that was
required to decrease
it's actually not vomiting it's gaping
which is like gagging um what they
showed was that thc could start doing
that at 0.5 milligrams per
kilogram if you look at the bar graph
you can see well
0.5 milligrams per kilogram also worked
for thca
but so did .05 so one tenth of the dose
of the of the required dose of thc
worked for thca
the effect of thca was reversed by a cb1
antagonist and so this led the
researchers to think well maybe it is
acting via a cb1 mechanism of action now
we don't think so i think if you block
the cb1 receptor most anti-nausea drugs
don't work that you know because
blocking that receptor can cause nausea
but the initial finding here was wow you
know one tenth of the dose of thc works
and if you 10x that dose of the thca it
doesn't make it any stronger so this
tiny tiny dose works
the researchers then went on
that same year to publish a paper on
cbda and one thing that's important to
note if you look at the bottom of the
bar graph they changed the units it was
milligrams per kilogram on the last
slide now it's micrograms per kilogram
so 1 1000th of that dose and you can see
here
that cbda started reducing nausea
at
0.5
micrograms a half of a microgram per
kilogram and then at one microgram per
kilogram it worked even better and and
that was kind of where it plateaued so
these are tiny tiny doses of cbda and
also there was no evidence of this
biphasic dose response effect let's
bring in another chart this is from an
older study same author from 2004
looking at the effect of different doses
of cbd on the nausea and vomiting model
and you can see
if we if we start
where it says 2.5 cbd and an licl is
lithium chloride that's the thing that's
making these rodents nauseous well you
can see 2.5
milligrams per kilogram of cbd perform
very similarly to the line that's to the
left of it the vehicle right so really
no effect at 2.5 then at 5 and 10 you
can see that cbd was reducing nausea but
at 25 and 40
cbd was increasing nausea
in that lithium chloride model so here's
that another example of that biphasic
dose response effect which did not show
up for cbda maybe if they had continued
to test higher doses they would have
found it maybe not
so moving on to another study by the
same group
that looked at
the same model lithium chloride induced
condition gaping in male rats and this
time they used some different
combinations they used cbd a combo of
cbd and thc cbda thca and then a
combination of cbda and thca
and um really interesting finding so
again here is the cbd graph this kind of
reproduced those earlier results from
2004 where you can see this by phasic
effect where cbd works in the sweet spot
but it's too high of a dose it actually
makes things worse
uh compared to over here
what we're what we're looking at is
um a study that's exploring the
mechanism of action so how is cbd
working and then also what's the
combined effect of cbd and thc so you
can see on the bar graph on the right
point one milligrams per kilogram of cbd
did basically nothing for this test
point one milligrams per kilogram of thc
did basically nothing but when you
combine these two ineffective doses of
thc and cbd that you do get a beneficial
effect you can see the bar graph on the
cbd plus thc line is a lot lower
then the researchers said well let's
look for the mechanism of action let's
try blocking the serotonin receptor
that's this way the next the next line
over the black bar and you can see
blocking serotonin
disrupted that synergistic effect
blocking the cb1 receptor also disrupted
that synergistic effect so there's
something happening when cbd and thc are
combined where the cb1 mechanism and the
serotonin mechanism are kind of working
together to make
the results greater than the sum of its
parts
now looking at the same study
incredibly low dose of cbda we're back
to milligrams per kilogram but this is
basically one tenth of a microgram per
kilogram this is just such a tiny
dose of cbda that was shown to work in
the same model
and then moving on we can see that a
very very tiny dose of thca also work
not as small as cbda but it also works
so we're seeing
much more powerful uh
effectiveness in this model of thc and
cbd compared to their neutral counter
parts
and then again looking at
the thca let's bring in that um that key
there so you can see they tested to see
well how is the thca working
they blocked the cb1 receptor and that
didn't stop it from working
that's this light gray bar the srt hca
all the way to the right the am630 they
blocked the cb2 receptor that didn't
seem to change anything but in the
middle there the
mk-86 they blocked a receptor called
p-par alpha and that inhibited the
therapeutic effects of thca p-power
alpha is an interesting target to keep
in mind so so far when we've been
talking about serotonin or cb1 receptors
or these ion receptors we're all talking
about targets that are on the outside of
the cell on the cell membrane the the p
part targets are actually located inside
the cell deep inside the cell on the
membrane of the nucleus the nucleus is
where all the genetic material is and
these nuclear receptors control the
expression of that genetic material so
when you're affecting p power alpha
you're actually changing which genes are
turned on and which are turned off and
the subsequent proteins that those genes
will code for so p power alpha seem to
be an important target for thca
and then the final slide from this study
is well what happens when we combine
these you can see that the teeny teeny
dose of cbda and a slightly larger dose
of thca
that were not significantly effective on
their own when they were combined again
we see that they were effective and then
the that combination was able to
be disrupted by blocking either
the p par alpha receptor that blocked it
quite a bit or by blocking the serotonin
receptor so again we're seeing some kind
of a synergy between these different
mechanisms of action so take home from
that is that tiny doses of these do a
lot in animal models of nausea and that
we are starting to elucidate some of the
mechanisms p power alpha and serotonin
let's move on to thca and animal models
of liver injury metabolic disease and
obesity
here's a study from 2020 that looked at
rodent models of chronic liver disease
and
also obesity induced liver injury
chemically induced liver injury as well
and study the effects of thca so here's
here's a little background main causes
of chronic liver disease in humans are
viral hepatitis alcohol and then what's
called non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
and obesity is a major risk factor for
that non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
basically
obesity can cause the liver to become
inflamed and fatty and then when the
liver is inflamed and fatty that makes
it the whole situation worse and can
lead to type 2 diabetes
high cholesterol and lipids in the blood
hypertension cardiovascular issues and
people get stuck in this vicious cycle
of liver and metabolic dysfunction
and so being able to interrupt that
cycle and restore balance to the system
is very important especially with
obesity being so prevalent
so here are some of the models that were
covered in this study first this is a
a chemically induced liver injury model
and what you can see on the y-axis is
fibrosis area so this is how much
scarring was going on in the liver and
you can see
the control on the left the light gray
not much scarring present when they just
add the um
the
chemical toxin to the liver then you can
see there's a lot of scarring
in the black bar then thca plus the
chemical toxin at 20 milligrams per
kilogram fairly high dose you can see
the scarring is reduced some and at 40
milligrams per kilogram also the
scarring is reduced a little bit more
the researchers also looked at not just
the level of scarring but the expression
of genes associated with inflammation
and what you can see over here is that
the il-6 gene the il-1b gene and the
tumor necrosis factor alpha gene
expressions were all decreased with the
treatment of thca so there's an
anti-inflammatory effect via this
likely this p-power mechanism right the
nuclear expression of those genes was
decreased
looking at another model from the same
study the rodents were fed either a
control diet or a high fat diet and then
their body weight was measured over time
so you can see on the left the gray bar
is the control diet
and then
you can see 15 18 or 23 weeks of the
high fat diet obviously the rodents
became heavier
looking at the
histology of that you can see in the
liver tissue
that there's a scarring and this
infiltrate of immune cells into the
tissue and you can see it just gets
worse and worse from 15 to 23 weeks and
the bar graph on the right shows just
how much scarring there is going on in
the liver over that time frame so
basically these animals are given
the non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
through diet
now when treated with the high fat diet
plus thca there's a few a couple
interesting things to look at so the uh
line
graph first you can see the red line is
the high fat diet plus the thca and you
can see that after
so these animals were allowed to get fat
you know they got obese and they got the
liver uh disease and then they were
treated with thca and what you see here
is their weight dropping you know the
the animals that were on the control
diet didn't change their weight and on
the high fat diet with no thca didn't
change their weight but what's
interesting is that the caloric intake
of these animals went down just a little
bit but not that much but their weight
really dropped so something was changing
there in the metabolism and then you can
see here that it was really their fat
mass that was dropping on uh
chart d
you can see the fat mass of the thca
treated animals went down but the lean
mass the muscle mass did not and this is
really desirable and a treatment for
obesity and metabolic syndrome we would
really want something that would help us
lose weight but lose that fatty weight
and not lose our muscle weight
same study looked at glucose levels you
can see
that even though they didn't return to
the level of the control animals
treating with thca brought down the
blood sugar of these rodents you can
also see that the insulin level was much
lower and the rodents treated with thca
so less insulin resistance more
sensitivity to insulin actually
completely reversed um you know
made their insulin sensitivity even a
little bit better than the control
animals
and then their triglycerides also came
down so now we're talking about one
compound from cannabis that's
non-psychoactive that at least in this
animal model has been shown to take
obese animals help them lose weight
lower their blood sugar or lower their
insulin lower their triglycerides
maintain their lean mass
decrease the amount of inflammatory
cells that have infiltrated the liver
that's what this slide is showing high
fat diet all those brown stains are the
inflammatory cells and then
the immune cells that are causing
inflammation in the liver thca reduces
that as well
reduces macrophages a similar story
there you can see the histology is quite
improved with the thca treatment and
then
as we mentioned decreasing fibrosis so
this is a high fat diet plus the thca
you can see there's a lot less scarring
in these animals
so that now again
these animals were treated with thca
i mentioned this older study that showed
that thc at 0.002 milligrams per
kilogram did protect the liver as well
so is that a possible confounder of
course that's possible could it be that
teeny dose of thc in there doing all the
work it could but i'd strongly suspect
that thca is doing the heavy lifting in
that previous data that i just showed
you
um another study looking at thca oh by
the way if you ever see it labeled like
thca hyphen a that's pretty much what
we're talking about there's another
version of thca called thca hyphen b it
appears in very low quantities most of
what the research is referring to is
this thcaa but anyways a little
background information from this study
that
glitazones are a class of diabetes ii
drugs and these have been used for
decades to target a different p power
receptor p par gamma
but they're and they work well for
diabetes but their use has decreased a
lot because they cause bone loss and
osteoporosis now it has been previously
shown that thca is a partial agonist at
this p par gamma receptor and so these
researchers were working with mice and
they were wondering does this dose of
thca 20 milligrams per kilogram which we
know is effective in protecting the
liver and all those great things we saw
in that previous study what happened to
these rodents when
they were treated with a high fat diet
for 12 weeks followed by three weeks of
treatment with thca
what they found was that
thca even though it stimulates p par
gamma like those other drugs probably
because it's a partial agonist and not a
strong agonist it did not cause the bone
loss or this fatty replacement
it did not increase the
fatty tissue of these rodents which
those other drugs can do it enhanced
osteoblastogenesis
in the bone marrow cells which means the
bone building
cells became stronger and more prevalent
it reduced body weight reduced fat mass
it reduced fatty liver and the mice that
were fed the high fat diet again this is
just three weeks of treatment after 12
weeks of the high fat diet
they found that it improved glucose
tolerance insulin sensitivity and
insulin profiles in the animals
it
induces browning of the white adipose
tissue so this is really a key to health
and longevity and it's getting more and
more attention it has to do with the
health of our mitochondria when um you
know when we uh say do uh cold bathing
or fasting
there's a variety of ways that we can
kind of induce this but basically our
white fat
is kind of a storage organ it just it
just stores calories it's not
metabolically active when we can turn
that into beige or brown fat the color
difference is based on the content of
mitochondria so
mitochondria are the powerhouses of the
cell it's where we make the energy for
the cell and by having a higher number
of mitochondria they tend to be smaller
mitochondria
and they work more efficiently they
don't make as many reactive oxygen
species they also produce more heat this
is really good for metabolism when you
can turn the storage tissue
of fat into a metabolically active
tissue very healthy
and then
last one from the study but for some
reason we got a blurry uh bar graph on
the bottom uh basically what i was just
pointing out with this page is that they
tried the same treatment on lean mice
and the only thing they saw change with
lean mice is that the mice produce more
heat increased thermogenesis but they
didn't lose weight because of it whereas
the high fat diet obese mice they also
started producing more heat but their
weight went down their inflammation went
down and the fatty liver improved so a
safe treatment that seems to selectively
act when the system is out of balance
and not um not going to create weight
loss in the in the control mice or the
lean mice
now again i'm not going to belabor this
but an old study at a fairly low dose
thc
uh oh not that old 2015 but thc at two
milligrams per kilogram was also able to
prevent diet induced obesity and mice
not necessarily
reverse it but well to some extent
reverse it but also prevent it
so that thc could always be a confounder
let's now move on
i think at the end here we're going to
focus on
gosh i've got a lot of slides left i'm
going to accelerate a bit and we might
not get to them all thca and cbda and
animal models of inflammatory pain
so a little background information thca
has anti-inflammatory and
neuroprotective effects via this p par
gamma receptor preclinical data suggests
that these p par gamma agonists can
protect against arthritis so these same
diabetes drugs
could help with severity of disease
inflammatory cells uh signaling
molecules like cytokines and then
cartilage and bone loss
but the clinical trials
and there have been clinical trials
especially with this uh this drug listed
here
that have shown a benefit in rheumatoid
arthritis patients
also cb1 positive allosteric modulators
we talked about this earlier have been
shown to help with pain
yet
without causing the cannabinoid memetic
effects which means without getting
people high or getting the animals um
you know slow or any of the signs of
that psychoactivity so again that
positive allosteric modulator is very
interesting mechanism of action so these
pictures i think are worth seeing this
was a
a collagen induced arthritis so they
inject collagen into the joint you can
see the mouse foot right there's the
control on the left cia is collagen
induced arthritis you can see how much
swelling there is in the foot then with
the collagen induced arthritis treated
with thca
pretty much no swelling maybe just a
slight amount
and then
that effect was able to be blocked by
blocking the ppar gamma receptor and
also by blocking the cb1 receptor so
maybe dual mechanisms of action maybe
that tiny bit of thc
was also helping
but really profound anti-inflammatory
results with thca in this study
and the authors measured lower levels of
these inflammatory molecules il-10 il-17
and the type 2 collagen sorry the the
images got a little translated and i
apologize for that
another study looking at inflammation
and pain this was carrageenan-induced
hyperalgesia
and swelling in a rodent model of
inflammatory pain they were given
various doses of cbda cbd and thc either
60 minutes before or after
the injection of carrageenan into the
paw and it's that injection that causes
the inflammation so again you can see
over in the top left
chart a you can see that 10 micrograms
were back in micrograms now 10
micrograms of cbda reduced the excessive
pain significantly and interestingly
there was a biphasic effect here a
thousand micrograms did not this was not
statistically significant so the lower
dose worked the higher dose both of them
are low but the ultra low dose worked
and the
fairly low dose did nothing
and then you can see uh similar results
when injected afterwards um oh and both
of these were after so the carrageenan
had already been injected
and then the uh
no i i apologize on the left we're
looking at pre-treatment so treating the
animals with cbda first
then injecting the carrageenan and then
measuring their pain either 180 minutes
after the injection or 360. you can see
somewhat of a long lasting effect there
for pain a very minor effect in the
swelling
after the treatment the results were
less profound that's the chart on the
right
and then um
yeah i apologize that this kind of
zoomed in somehow so i'm not going to be
able to fully go through this slide but
i think basically the take-home was that
very tiny doses of cbda that were
ineffective and relatively low doses of
thc that were ineffective when combined
together there was a synergistic effect
so this was a study showing that cbda
and thc worked well together for pain
and inflammation and that's something
that i've seen clinically as well
let's talk a little bit about absorption
and distribution one study looked at
these compounds um in a model of
epilepsy and the big question was are
the acidic cannabinoids even getting
into the brain
and
another slide that didn't work but the
answer is barely at all they do get in
there
but much lower what we would call the
blood-brain ratio is much lower with
these compounds than their neutral
counterparts so cbda can cross the
blood-brain barrier but doesn't do it
nearly as well as cbd
however once it is in the brain it seems
to work more effectively it has stronger
potency or efficacy
another example from the study cbda and
this
this is just one seizure model in
rodents but it had an anti-convulsant
effect at 10 and 30 milligrams per
kilogram that's the dose they gave the
animal which was a lot lower than the
same model for cbd 100 milligrams per
kilogram so again think of one tenth of
the dose of cbda is working
even though barely any of it is getting
into the brain so it seems to be a
powerful agent but the little bit that
does get into the brain seems to do a
lot
um so that's part of the
pharmacokinetics gets absorbed well into
the blood but not great into the brain
and then this was a transdermal i
thought it was interesting to point out
that these acidic cannabinoids do get
absorbed well through the skin at least
in dogs so this was a fairly low dose
for dogs of mostly cbda
a little bit of thca
and then also see a fair amount of cbd
so you can see the composition of the
ointment here and that was rubbed into
the ears of six beagles twice daily for
two weeks
and you can see that they had
much higher blood levels of cbda than
they did cbd so transdermally cbda seems
to be better absorbed than cbd as well
and it also had an anti-inflammatory
effect in these dogs
moving on this was a mouse study that
looked at
how well these different cannabinoid
compounds are absorbed either by
themselves or in combination with each
other now when we take fat soluble
compounds like
say like a vitamin a and vitamin e
they're both fat soluble if you take
them at the same time they're going to
compete for absorption and so you're not
going to get full absorption you would
actually do better to space them out a
little bit and take them with fatty
foods so that you can more fully absorb
each one that's expected to be the case
and is the case with the neutral
cannabinoids and so
um but something something stood out
different here um what i'll show you is
these acidic cannabinoids when given
this is cbd va and cbga so we haven't
talked much about these yet but you can
see that when given as a pure compound
that's the dotted line their absorption
was much better than when given in a
compound in combination with a bunch of
their kind of brothers and sisters from
the cannabis plant same thing for cbga
and really all the other acidic
cannabinoids they tested except
cbda
for some reason when cbda was given in
an extract of cannabis with a bunch of
other cannabinoid compounds it got
absorbed way better than it did by
itself
was not the case for cbd the one that
really stood out with cbda so why does
it get absorbed so much better in the
context of a broad spectrum of
cannabinoid compounds and these
researchers figured out the answer
which um
how are we gonna do this sorry so i got
messed up again i really apologize for
that the answers is quite profound and
that is
that we have these e-flux pumps in our
intestine so basically when things get
absorbed into the intestine from the
lumen the inside of the intestine into
the the bloodstream
some of them are actually kicked back
out into the intestine we have these
pumps that will kick things out and that
happens for cbda it happens for a lot of
compounds these researchers discovered
that both thc
and cbg
were able to inhibit that efflux effect
on cbda meaning that when cbda is taken
with very small amounts of cbg or thc
its absorption is phenomenal
phenomenally higher much much higher
when taken with those two compounds
something to remember
i'm to skip over a few things here but
just to just to show you some of the
absorbability of these compounds in
humans we do have some human data
that looked at um
medication these were nine patients with
medication overuse headache that we're
taking two different compounds you can
see them at the top of the slide one was
a cannabis oil one was a cannabis
decoction which is like a tea and they
both were had very low potencies
contained some cbda and some thca and
they were kind of like you know
partially decarboxylated uh preparations
but what you can see in both of these
charts is that this orange line is
standing out this is the comp the blood
concentration over time and what you'll
see is that
way more thca was absorbed than thc
and also um i mean the the thca the thc
line is in gray it's so low to the
bottom it's it's hard to perceive there
there were the same results with cbda
even more impressive look at the
absorption of cbda compared to cbd now
if you look at the oil for example you
can see there were roughly similar
levels of cbda and cbd there was more
cbda but not even double the amount and
look at how much more was absorbed and
when you crunch the numbers
it turns out that in t
or decoction
thca was absorbed 50 times better than
thc and cbda cbda was absorbed about
five times better than cbd also pretty
impressive results in the oil as well 32
times better absorption of thca and 11
times better absorption of cbda so
theoretically we need a lot less of
these compounds when used
therapeutically and we have another
pharmacokinetic study in humans but
because of time i'm going to skip over
that and just go really quickly to the
covet data so this made headlines
and what they what these researchers
basically did was um
use a
a technique to see
you know basically throw a bunch of
compounds at the spike protein and see
what binds the spike protein and what
they found was that from cannabis the
three compounds that bound the spike
protein the best were the cbga
the thca
and the cbda these really bound on to
the spike protein now the researchers
weren't able to continue working with
thca so they continued with cbga and
cbda but we would expect the results to
be similar they modeled it out and they
showed yes we understand where these
molecules are likely binding to the
spike protein and then they tested it in
um live cells in vitro and then they
also tested it in animals to see
if this is binding the spike protein
does it actually prevent the virus from
infecting the cell and the answer was a
very strong yes you can see that as well
it got a little cut off but i think you
can see it here as the dose of both cbda
and cbga went up its ability to prevent
infection or to neutralize the infection
and ended up going up and these were at
i would say potentially clinically
relevant concentrations uh maybe a
little on the high side of what we could
achieve in blood or tissue
but but not far outside the range and i
discussed that in detail on a previous
webinar
which is um in the healer training
program
so you can see they also tested it with
three different uh varieties uh three
different variations of the covid or the
sars cove 2 virus and it was effective
at all of them
so i'm just going to wrap it up now how
to implement this into your life i think
you get the point these are powerful
compounds they're not inactive
precursors they're highly bioavailable
highly complementary and in some cases
synergistic with the neutral
cannabinoids so how do i recommend this
to my patients cannabis tea is a very
effective way to do this take a little
bud throw it in your cup pour some
boiling water over it let it let it sip
steep and drink it or throw it in your
coffee or your tea it'll change the
flavor a little bit but it's a nice way
to get these now i want to warn you that
if you use something fatty in your tea
like a creamer or whole milk or
something like that then you're going to
be increasing the solubility of thc
if you just use water you would you
would have to be very sensitive to thc
or you have a very very big cup of tea
in order to get enough thc to actually
have a psychoactive effect or an
impairing effect
but if you if you had that coffee
creamer that might change the story the
tea water at 212 degrees does not cause
much decarboxylation and
while thc has low solubility in water
thca has higher solubility so that's
mostly what you're going to be getting
you can also just make a cold ethanol
tincture out of raw cannabis flour and
it's going to be mostly thca and then if
you don't want to take the time to do
that literally just take a little bud
and eat it depending on the variety that
you're using that'll
be a pretty good dose of thca and or
cbda
now what i've seen clinically is that
when people are using the raw
cannabinoids they don't get pain relief
like on day one which sometimes they do
with with thc and sometimes even with
cbd i think that
the effects tend to build over time and
that's probably because the mechanism of
action is more of an anti-inflammatory
mechanism than an analgesic mechanism
however the anti-emetic the anti-nausea
effects can be super rapid i've had
people that have not responded to smoked
cannabis take a little bit of a cannabis
flower chew it a couple times and stick
it in their cheek let it mix with their
saliva and five minutes later the nausea
is gone so uh these both thca and cbda
are very good anti-nausea agents in my
experience cbda tends to have higher
potency than cbd and at healer my
company we produce
products our cbd product has some cbda
in it it's about 15 cbda and then we
have a cbda dominant product i was just
looking at the comments that we got
recently and a lot of our users find
that they're able to use like a quarter
to a half of the dose
if they use the cbda product they find
that cbda gives them the benefits of cbd
but at a much lower dose and then just
final take home point thc and thca are
quite different pharmacologically they
have some overlap but it's not that
clinically significant whereas cbd and
cbda are very similar just the
bioavailability and the potency is
different
and that
is the end of my presentation i invite
you all to check out my work on
healer.com we have a whole lot of free
it's totally complementary patient
education there to help anyone get good
results with cannabis we also have a
paid training program and then if you're
interested in our cbda or other hemp
products you can find those on
healercbd.com
and that is the end of my presentation
thank you so much
and thank you dustin for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live q a portion of this
webinar if you have any questions
this is a good time to ask please just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
so let's get started we already have
some great questions coming in
great
our first question from an audience
member is is the thca plus cbda
synergistic effect on nausea by
by phasic if i see iphasic yes so great
question it does not appear to be even
though perhaps if those researchers had
brought in the range of doses that they
tested they would have seen that but in
the data that we have no it does not
just and it does not seem to be biphasic
now um
what i didn't mention is that clinically
i have observed especially thca to
sometimes have biphasic effects there
there tends to be a sweet spot with that
drug and not necessarily for nausea but
for other conditions
cbda i haven't observed that very much
thank you so much now justin how do you
decide
cbd or thca for seizures
a great question so
um
right we talked about how thca can work
for seizures
when i'm seeing somebody with seizures
who's new to cannabis i'm kind of
thinking about it in three different
ways you know would this what should be
my first treatment approach thc which is
always a consideration cbd or thca and
the way i decide that is that thc will
often produce side benefits for
comorbidities like if somebody can't
sleep if somebody's in pain if somebody
has
a lot of nausea or other gi effects
going on i'll lean towards the thc
cbd tends to be a little harder on the
gut so if there's gi things i'll lean
away from cbd but it tends to be really
good for uh helping cognition so and
people that have developmental delay or
trouble thinking um cbd is often my
go-to thca when i'm using it to treat
seizures it seems to have less of these
side effects less side benefits less
negative side effects but one of the
ways that it really shines is that
usually it's effective in very low doses
when it is effective so it ends up
becoming a must a much more cost
effective treatment so for someone
that's worried about cost or doesn't
have a lot of financial resources as
many of you probably know treating
seizures with cbd can be extremely
expensive
thca is often effective in these tiny
tiny doses can be a little harder to
find a good uh consistent thca formula
and then as i mentioned before it can be
finicky sometimes we'll start at a low
dose we'll titrate up and we'll see some
benefit and then as we continue to
titrate the benefit goes away and we
have to actually reduce the dose again
to regain that anti-epileptic effect
thank you so much we have time for a few
more questions
any thoughts on the role of terpenes in
the described effect of thca
i think that when people like clinically
when we're taking uh you know cannabis
tea or eating the raw bud yes we are or
even products that are
produced with great care to maintain the
acidic state of these cannabinoids uh
those products are likely to have more
of the terpenes in them just because a
lot of the terpenes evaporate when that
when the decarboxylation happens or
typically that's how it goes so i would
expect people that are using thca to get
more exposure to the terpenes however in
a lot of these studies
these were purified compounds so
i think a lot of the data that i showed
you today was not confounded by
terpenes even though i i think the
terpenes are very therapeutic it's at
low doses so it's a very good question
thank you so much
now our next question i would like to
understand which is better for treatment
cbda
and thca or cbd and thc
and the second part of this is in the
future will we use more of that
acid cannabinoids
so i mean the answer is all of the above
right one of our most successful
formulas um that healer produces in the
medical market here in maine and
maryland is called healer balance which
contains equal proportions of cbda thca
cbd and thc i think you saw that
cbda can outshine cbd in some cases
however it doesn't uh necessarily get
into the brain even though it might be
more potent in the brain and so there's
probably some rationale for including
everything here you saw examples of thc
and cbda working really well together
for pain and inflammation examples of
thc and thca working together so i think
it's all of the above what i would
really like to emphasize for
people that are making cannabis products
is do not fully decarboxylate even if
you leave 10 or 15 percent of that
acidic form you're likely going to have
a more broadly effective and more potent
product that will also be more cost
effective
thank you so much now are there reliable
commercial formulations of thca
it's hard to do for for years we
you know instructed the parents of our
seizure patients to kind of do an
ethanol extract lay it out on a
thin tray and then blow a fan over it so
that you can evaporate the ethanol i
mean it's hard to do at low heat healer
developed
an extraction method
that actually part of it is patented
that allows us to do this with very low
levels of well it's actually very cold
and also very low pressure
and so we take our time we we pay
special attention um to maintaining that
thca so yes we have thca formulas um
through the healer brand that's only
available in maine and maryland and then
um
i think other markets are starting to uh
you know offer thca products but it's
early it's it's absolutely early
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these
great questions we have time for two
more questions
is this essential for
is this helpful for essential tremors
how do you take it
essential tremors um
you know it's it's challenging to treat
my
i haven't had a lot of great results
with essential tremors people come in
with that problem and they end up
getting better sleep and other aspects
of their life is better when we treat
them
but the tremor itself
doesn't always respond to cannabis but
still i would say the best success i've
had with essential tremors is with thc
and sometimes when oral thc doesn't work
i would lean towards the inhaled thc
which can be helpful
thank you so much we have time for one
more question
great questions coming in how can cbd
users get started with cbda
yeah so i i mean i they're very
compatible so depending on if you're if
you feel like you're getting good
results from cbd i would encourage you
to add a little cbda like say five or 10
milligrams and see if you notice
anything
more effective happening and then try
staying on that cbda and discontinuing
the cbd i have a lot of people that are
able to completely switch over from cbd
to cbda they don't feel like they're
missing anything from the cbd they're
getting better results saving money so
it's something that i encourage a lot of
cbd users to try
justin i want to thank you for your time
today and for important research before
we go do you have any quick closing
remarks speak for our audience
ah no no um i i've said enough thank you
so much for your time and attention we
packed a lot into this hour i hope that
i've gotten you excited about the acidic
cannabinoids test them out in your own
life send us an email let us know what
you're noticing these these are powerful
compounds
absolutely and before we go i want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time to answer
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of your
registration and this webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years until
march 20 24. labyrinths will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone
be safe bye-bye
thank you
you